hi I'm Eve aka madam Medtronic as the
all new national living statue
championship is coming up this April
I've made a video of my top five living
statue tips alongside one of my makeup
routines
tip one look after your skin a lot of
face paint can be harsh on your skin so
it is a good idea to moisturize before
and after a show I always use coconut
oil or Vaseline to act as a slight
barrier under the makeup I also
personally find that removing face paint
with soap and hot water rather than
makeup wipes is better for your skin in
the long run tip to get comfy okay maybe
not that comfy you're likely to be
standing in the same pose for long
periods of time so you want to make sure
it's a comfortable one try not to tense
your muscles too much as this leads to
uncontrolled shaking and often cramp
also I'd avoid holding your arms above
shoulder level for too long as blood
circulation becomes more difficult tip 3
good coverage now this might sound
obvious but as you can see in the video
it's really important to cover every
tiny bit of skin that might be on show
because trust me is quite obvious in
daylight and the audience members do
come up and check
tip for don't get dizzy standing for
long periods of time can lower your
blood pressure and blood sugar levels to
prevent possible dizzy spells it's
important to make sure you keep hydrated
and eat well it also helps to maintain a
good body temperature which leads me to
tip fights prepare for all weathers now
this is England it's often cold and it
rains a lot
so waterproofing your costumes are
making sure you can fit lots of layers
underneath is really useful you'll be
surprised at how cold you can get when
you can't move to keep warm equally for
those precious hot days having a cooler
more breathable costume and trying to
keep out of direct sunlight for long
periods of time can help with
overheating
okay so I've been mother Medtronic I
hope you've enjoyed my top tips you can
find out more about me on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram or better yet you
could come and find me at the national
living statues championships in April in
stratford-upon-avon